when you think of the term welfare queen
you might picture someone like this
but i would like to invite you to the
possibility that an actual welfare queen
looks like this
now don't know what i mean let me
explain in a segment called how did we
get here
in the united states a lot of people
don't like welfare they think that
people who receive welfare are
benefiting disproportionately from the
money we all pull together as a society
to help those in need and many americans
have the idea that most of the people
unfairly receiving that help are people
of color but are they let's go back to
1954. it's the year of brown versus the
board of education of topeka and equally
important the year peanut m ms were
invented
now brown versus the board of education
of topeka was not a versus battle
between james brown and a bunch of
kansas school teachers although that
would be great and i would watch the
butt off of it
brown versus board of education was
actually five civil rights cases all put
together one of them involved the south
carolina school district that only
provided school buses for their white
students the black students has had to
cross a river and walk up to 16 miles to
and from school it's like if a triathlon
was swimming running and algebra two and
instead of meadows you gotta get up and
do it again the next day but here's the
important part it's not just that the
education for black kids was unequal
that particular school district was 75
black so that means black parents tax
dollars were literally being used to
build better lives for the white kids
now you might call that a unique
distribution of funds but i call it
welfare for white people because the
white kids were disproportionately
benefiting from the money that was
raised to take care of everyone now in
brown versus board of education the
supreme court ruled that segregation in
public schools was illegal but that
didn't stop white parents from getting
their kids more government handouts
one publix once public schools couldn't
be segregated anymore a lot of white
parents started opening private
all-white schools called segregation
academies which is the most on the nose
name i have ever heard you might as well
have called it racist prep i mean
segregation academy go ahead and call it
on the ones and threes elementary
but
the crazy thing about segregation
academies aside from the name is that
almost 200 of those schools still exist
today
segregation academies are one of those
things that should have disappeared
decades ago but somehow didn't like
low-rise genes or bill maher
or
bill maher
and here's the thing white students are
now the minority in public schools it
makes sense less than half of the u.s
population under 18 is caucasian but
private schools are still very white
like naming your kid braid in white or
pronouncing target target what
like dancing like this white
like
what is that what are you doing are you
feeling a smell what is this
as of 2017 67
of private school students were white
that's two-thirds in a nation as diverse
as ours our private schools somehow have
the same racial makeup as the triplets
on this is us
now i know what you're thinking
shouldn't parents be free to send their
school send their kids to any school
that they can afford yes of course they
should but here's the thing no one
mentions you and i are paying for those
schools
in 23 states your tax dollars are being
used to send kids to private and
religious schools in florida alone
residents pay almost 1 billion dollars a
year to send kids to private schools to
put that in perspective that's slightly
more than florida spends on illegal
fireworks and just a touch less than
their meth budget
so now we know where to find america's
white kids they're in private school
meanwhile 70 70 of our black children
are going to high poverty public schools
while their parents taxes are being used
to fund majority white private schools
now what rubs many white americans wrong
about welfare is the idea that they pay
a bunch of money in taxes and then
someone else benefits meanwhile black
parents are paying taxes so that their
kids can go to the school from lean on
me while a lot of white kids can go to
the school from dead poets society
i'm just taking other people's word
there there's no way i can sit through
that movie but
let's be clear i'm sure it's great but
let's be clear
the problem isn't just the private
schools no these welfare kings and
queens have also found a way to make
their public schools wider through a
move called succession
secession through a move called
succession succession is something else
it's a great tv show
it's through a move called secession and
if that word has negative connotations
for you that is because you are a human
being with a memory secession happens
when part of a school district decides
to leave the hole in practice it's when
white people
in a district decide they want their own
school system so they create a new one
leaving behind the students of color the
term secession sounds old-timey and
historical but it's something that's
actually happening right now from 2000
to 2017 47 school districts in the u.s
seceded from larger school districts and
every single one of those new districts
is majority white
basically the concept of secession is a
lot like the tv show succession and by
that i mean it's a bunch of greedy white
nonsense
so
here's the question if welfare is a
small group of people unfairly draining
money from the taxes that are collected
from everyone then when it comes to
education who's actually receiving
welfare
and who's paying for that welfare
you and i are and if you're not happy
about that go to your local school board
meeting and speak up but when you walk
into that meeting watch out for welfare
queens no not her
him this has been how did we get here
[Music]
you